okay okay it's wrong it's wrong
um how is it wrong
there should be a two there but how did
i know there should be a two there
um well here's my tip okay remember that
and if you're going back to i think it's
like the
um no this is 3b right yeah three a
right the reason why three a and b
are together um is because i'll move
this
they're both to do with pascal's
triangle right did you notice that
do you remember how i i showed you i
mean it was kind of obvious
in the in 3a that it was pascal's trying
because it's like
that one plus that one is that one right
that's that's how it works okay now this
is also from pascal's triangle the
question is how
well think about what it means what does
the top number the m
right or in this case the n plus two
what does it signify
it signifies the row you're in right and
then these numbers down the bottom
the r's and the r minus ones and so on
they refer to okay well which
um which item which which term in that
row do you want to pick out
okay so the easy way you can see why i
stuck a two there and it's going to make
all your algebra
happy okay is because this means there's
a relationship between
um the terms in one row and the terms
in the row two rows down right actually
there's always relationships
for the further down but it starts to
get you start to get too many terms okay
so the question is
which one or ones so let's draw it out a
little bit
you need to draw it a few rows down
before it becomes a bit more obvious
let's stop say um
yeah here i'll do here okay now let's
pick out a turn
like say one of the tens in this bottom
row here
okay now by the way um which row is this
now it's a bit tricky right but if you
if you remember how we rewrote it
right um we call this the zeroth row
which is slightly awkward but it's
it's to make the notation work okay so
that's no choice nor
this is one choose not one sorry one
choose one
and this is going to be because
otherwise you get to here you can't call
that the second row because this number
won't be
sorry the first row because it wouldn't
be enough so this is the
one two three four fifth row okay so
therefore tan
is equal to 5 choose
3. i choose what
zero this can't be if i choose one right
because it's it's there's only one way
to do it so that's five choose naught
five choose one five choose two five
choose three
okay which is indeed equal to ten but
you know apart from all these binomial
coefficients and that kind of thing and
how that works
how do you get it in year seven well you
just say look this number comes from
these two
numbers right and then you say well
where did those two numbers come from
well they came from the ones above right
this is the n plus two
and the anthro that we're now talking
about okay well how did i get six and
four
i got six by saying three plus three
right
and i got four by saying one plus
ah right okay so that's why
you can know there's a two there because
that two
corresponds to this term okay now i
could write it out if you like
it's a bit boring it looks like that
okay you can see i had some trouble
before i got there too
okay but um that's how i knew that's
that's what's going to make it
work okay because this is where it comes
from this is where the numbers come from
right
so the reason why i thought it's worth
drawing everyone's attention to it
rather than just saying
put a two there okay is because you need
to be able to make the connection
between
yeah they're binomials and factorials
and this that the other but they also
come from a very similar
simple structure that you know how to
build okay and um
that that value will take you a long way
right always remember that
they're really saying the same thing